now a day after the taliban reassured
the world people will be safe under its
rule its fighters have reportedly opened
fire on protesters
in our reports three people were killed
at the demonstration against the group's
takeover of the eastern city of
jalalabad people were marching in the
streets chanting and carrying the afghan
flag video of the event later showed
taliban fighters firing into the air and
hitting protesters with sticks
rob mcbride has the latest from kabul
i think it's being seen as really since
the taliban just assumed power a couple
of days ago as the first major active
defiance against them
jalalabad is a very important city it is
east of here towards the border with
pakistan and this protest began over the
national flag now since the taliban have
taken power they have very consciously
been removing the afghan national flag
and replacing it with the taliban flag
we've seen that a lot uh here in the
capital kabul it's left a lot of people
are very upset but people are by and
large put up with it especially here in
kabul well it seems in jalalabad people
have not put up with it they have there
has been a protest uh people kicked back
and pushed back against this several
hundred people took to the streets uh
proudly waving their afghan flags they
marched on a square apparently and put
the afghan flag back up after it had
been removed by the taliban and this
resulted in a clash with the taliban
themselves initially we understand
taliban fighters began firing in the air
trying to disperse the protesters and
then it seems the firing was more direct
into the crowd resulting in deaths and
injuries so it is very serious incident
there was another protest over the same
issue the
the removal of the national flag in the
province of cost that it again involves
several hundred people so it is an
emotive issue here and it does come at a
sensitive time this is the eve of
afghanistan's independence day when we
might expect it that uh well feelings
are running high and there is a
possibility of more protests and the
possibility of more clashes
jan egland is the general secretary of
the norwegian refugee council he says
his main concern are the refugees who
fear for their future
our focus is on the internally displaced
the hundreds and hundreds of thousands
uh on top of the millions before this
latest emergency in the country i mean
the the the international airport which
has all eyes on it now will be organized
by american and other forces there's a
lot of attention on what's happening
there our concern are the millions and
millions who are now starving
who are very afraid of of
of their existence in the future
hundreds of thousands were displaced
because of the fighting because of the
crossfire
but others were also displaced by fear
of what was now
coming
um there could be less bloodshed now
there could be because the the the
conflict between the taliban and the
afghan
army the previous african army and the
international forces seem to be over
and and that should enable people to
return to their homes we're doing a lot
of work in in norwegian refugee council
to secure house land and property for
the displaced and for returning refugees
if anyone are coming so that they can
have a new and durable solution to the
plight but at the moment
most operations are in hibernation there
is there are new rulers uh it's it's
really a period of of tremendous uh you
know seismic changes
afghanistan's deposed president is in
the united arab emirates the foreign
ministry says ashwagani and his family
are in abu dhabi on humanitarian grounds
while the taliban have taken charge of
the country we're still waiting to hear
the makeup of a future government the
taliban says it will be inclusive on
wednesday a member of the taliban
political office anas haqqani was
pictured meeting national reconciliation
chairman abdullah abdullah and the
former president hamid karzai in kabul
the taliban's co-founder and political
chief has returned to afghanistan
abdulhani baradar arrived to a crowd of
supporters in kandahar the birthplace of
the taliban baradar led the group's
negotiators in talks with the u.s and
afghan government
earlier in the day baradar met qatar's
foreign minister before leaving doha
where those talks had been held he was
freed from a prison in pakistan at the
request of the u.s three years ago
and after taking power in kabul the
afghan taliban is now in talks with the
pakistani government kamal haider has
more on that from tor humble the
crossing
a senior afghan delegation comprising of
senior afghan leaders is in pakistan at
the moment they've already held an
important round of talks with the
country's military leadership they've
met the pakistani prime minister
pakistan is stressing on the point that
this has to be an inclusive government
the taliban have already signaled that
they will tolerate other religious
minorities as well as ethnicities within
afghanistan to form an inclusive
government it is going to be important
to see what kind of progress will be
made in reaching a political settlement
in the meantime the pakistani foreign
minister is planning to visit turkey and
also hold consultation with peripheral
states such as iran turkmenistan
uzbekistan tajikistan and also with
their chinese counterparts pakistan has
played a lead role in facilitating the
talks between the afghan taliban and the
united states it is acting as a
facilitator and of course what happens
here in islamabad will be crucial but it
is also important to note that pakistan
is watching
cautiously the moves inside afghanistan
the signs are good this is the first
time in decades that the people of
afghanistan have a ray of hope in
reaching a political settlement to the
afghan conflict now the british prime
minister says the uk will do all it can
to avert a humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan but boris johnson says he
doesn't believe military action against
the taliban is an option he made the
comments while addressing the british
parliament it was recalled early to
discuss the taliban takeover of
afghanistan
i think it would be fair to say that the
events in afghanistan have unfolded and
the collapse has been faster i think
even the taliban themselves predicted
what is not true is to say that the uk
government uh was unprepared or did not
foresee this because uh it was certainly
part of our planning op pitting the very
difficult uh logistical operation for
the withdrawal of uk nationals has been
under preparation uh for many months mr
speaker and i can tell the house that
the
decision to commission the emergency
handling center at the airport the
commissioning of that center took place
two weeks ago mr speaker
joe nahal is in london with more now
this is a country deeply invested in
afghanistan after 20 years of that nato
mission the uk of course the
second senior partner in the nato
alliance after the u.s it was an
opportunity for mps to have their say to
discuss what has happened to talk about
what little this country can perhaps now
contribute to help in the aftermath
we've seen some
extremely moving poignant sometimes
bitter and angry interventions from mps
some of them veterans of that campaign
in afghanistan we've seen strong
questions asked to the government about
its preparedness for all of this boris
johnson and his foreign secretary were
on holiday as these events unfolded and
escalated towards the end of last week
we've had questions about the failures
of western intelligence
to be able to predict what would happen
and questions about whether more could
have been done
to form some kind of a coalition without
the united states to stand strong in
afghanistan and
head off prevent what in effect happened
the government has tried to talk up
the positives the successes there have
been they have been offered by the
government of double the annual amount
of of international humanitarian aid
going into afghanistan despite cuts
elsewhere 300 million dollars it has set
aside not to be given to the taliban of
course but to be given to humanitarian
organizations and the u.n boris johnson
has asked for the un
to lead a humanitarian mission
in the region there's talk of resettling
refugees there's talk about bringing
back afghan support staff double the
number now they're hoping to bring back
10 000 at a rate of around a thousand a
day according to the home secretary
fathan
is the chairperson for the afghanistan
women's council she says the taliban
should explain what version of islamic
law plans to apply and as soon as
possible
am not afraid from the taliban but i
want from the taliban to be run as soon
as possible security peace to stop the
war in afghanistan for the afghan woman
is very very important for us is is
to stop the war in killing and security
and second the taliban should to explain
which kind of chariot they are bringing
afghanistan because afghan people afghan
women they are muslim
we are alhamdulillah muslim we are not
afraid from by the name of sharia but we
want to be sure what do you say about
women's right we want to see uh
turn out just talking about women's
right very nicely very currently but we
want to see uh what they are doing what
is program for
future for the afghan woman i'm not
afraid i'm fighting i want state to
fight him for peace for democracy for
women's rights for human rights put i am
a leader of afghan women i work more
than four decades for my country the
thing taliban say now is nice about
women's i
i i try to believe i still with hope uh
we are working
we are just waiting for few days more